todavía hace falta que el jurado
nacional de elecciones resuelva las
actas impugnadas que keiko fujimori y
sus abogados interpusieron ante el
organismo electoral los funcionarios se
hacen sus mayores esfuerzos para atender
con celeridad los reclamos de keiko
fujimori pero tal como me lo han
señalado expertos en derecho electoral
el proceso es complicado y todavía
podría extenderse quizás entre dos o
tres semanas más para que se declare un
nuevo presidente del perú francisco
háblenos del clima social pero ya estaba
sumamente polarizado previo a las
elecciones y el resultado no con esta
diferencia tan estrecha lo demuestra de
hecho cómo describirías entonces el
escenario social que se vive por estos
días en perú
de impredecible cada día salen los
peruanos a las calles y plazas divididos
en bandos
a favor de keiko fujimori otros a favor
de pedro castillo cada cual declarando
un vencedor de las elecciones los ánimos
comenzaron a calentarse este fin de
semana cuando políticos de derecha
vinculados a keiko fujimori sugirieron
la realización de nuevas elecciones esto
ha motivado que los seguidores de pedro
castillo califiquen de golpistas a los
fujimoristas y éstos a su vez acusen de
fraude a los votantes de pedro castillo
esta situación ha motivado que la alta
comisionada de la organización de
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos
michelle bachelet exprese su
preocupación por el incremento de la
atención del perú y haya hecho un
llamado para que se eviten nuevos
conflictos sociales entre los peruanos
francisco zacarías completísimo reporte
desde la capital